Congress has no authority over
major-league baseball but that hasn't
stopped them from holding dozens of
hearings on the national pastime over
the years federal legislators have
relished the opportunity to show off
their populists appeal in front of
national TV cameras by talking inside
baseball jargon an awful lot of my
constituents would like to see Pete Rose
in the Hall of Fame acting as moral
scolds BASEketball is gonna be priced
out of the fans market and generally
probing in places they don't belong mr.
Clemens do you recall any bleeding
through your pants in 2001 to celebrate
this year's opening day reasontv
presents the top 5 pointless
congressional hearings on baseball in
2005 Rafael Palmeiro gave a finger wag
for the ages let me start by telling you
this I have never used steroids period
homero would fail a
performance-enhancing drug test a few
months later but congressman Davis was
there to ensure the public that Congress
was making baseball's records its
business you as a baseball fan do you
think after this episode that he should
be qualified for the hole in the
legislation that's introduced by Senator
McCain and Senator bunny the preamble
for that says that those records should
go by the wayside in two thousand noted
free-market conservative George will
tried to convince Congress that
socialism was the only way to save the
Montreal Expos is the federal government
instead of being alarmed by Microsoft
would be alarmed by them breaking up the
Expos this sounds I know to some people
like socialism L would be shocked well
Rick Levin said exclaimed one day in our
deliberations as I was applying
compassionate conservatism to the small
market teams of Major League Baseball
that he was going back to Yale to say
that he was to the right of me on this
issue in 2001 governor Jesse Ventura was
a rare voice of reason expressing
skepticism that billionaire team owners
were hemorrhaging money and needed
public funds to build them new stadiums
I just like to ask when they talk about
losing all this money do they not deduct
it off their taxes as if it's a loss if
they're doing that they're truly not
losing the money that they claim to be
losing in most cases they companies the
individual does not do
but I guess governor I'd have to say to
you if you want to have a tax loss or
lose 50 or 60 million dollars I think
there are better ways to create a tax on
and having a 60 million dollar loss I
don't think anybody that's why I'm a
hard time believing it mr. selig that
they're losing that kind of money and
still paying the salaries they're paying
it's asinine these people did not get
the wealth they have being stupid than
that there's some combination of private
public financing the stadium or any
other remedy you could tell us when we
take public money and we build a public
library with public money you don't have
to pay to get in it and yet here we pay
public money and we build a stadium and
then they charge the very public who
built it to give in it in 2008 Roger
Clemens faced off with his former
trainer Brian McNamee over the latter's
accusation that he provided the former
side Young Award winner with
performance-enhancing drugs for years
let me be clear I've never taken
steroids or HGH congressman Davis
insured the public interest was being
served you testified in your deposition
that mr. Clemens on one occasion bled
through his designer pants and that's
when he bought band-aids so he then he
always traveled now with those little
band-aids for his but if he bled that's
your quote mr. Clemens do you recall any
bleeding through your pants in 2001 I
don't but no congressional hearing on
baseball can top the overwrought
histrionics of 1995 session regarding
the ongoing players strike there's no
joy here in Washington's we resume these
hearings just a sense of loss of lost
opportunities lost innocence lost a chip
a game that once symbolize America like
no other Senator Joe Biden made bizarre
and conflicting threats I thought when I
was chairman of this committee and I
think now and we should have hearings on
all sports I'm angry that we're even
here having to deal with this as a
Congress it's not something we should be
doing but I think we should look at all
sports here one of the things I thought
about doing is maybe which would please
a lot of people given up this job and
starting a national organization to
boycott baseball when you do come back
senator Alan Simpson long for the days
when baseball players have no rights to
choose their employer or negotiate their
salaries baseball was a great game
when players made an awful lot less if
one has to have millions to reduce one
to stay in this game him then baseball
is better off without them and we are
told that there's nothing Congress
should do about it Simpson also
expressed his frustration that bud selig
owner of the Milwaukee Brewers had been
serving as acting commissioner for more
than two years I don't know how many
times by so many I've been assured that
the appointment of a commissioner was
quote just around the corner where are
we now know commissioner no baseball
understand that as soon as we have a
labor agreement there will be a strong
and independent commissioner I'm
concerned whether or not BASEketball is
going to be priced out of the fans
market obviously we share your concern
about ticket prices I just want to cover
that very quickly in the last 25 also
your hotdog prices your pop going prices
you everything else the whole prices of
everything else is gonna be if we got to
danger pricing though but I I'm angry
that we're even here having to deal with
this as a Congress